all right so let's talk about black
lives matter and you i think you've done
a couple of videos on black lives matter
and
my my feeling is that the movement has
changed again
from what i would describe as something
that was well intentioned trying
to deal with some seriously big problems
related to law enforcement
and their treatment of the black
community that i think most people
realize is somewhat legitimate at some
level right
i'm trying to i'm trying to be somewhat
politically correct here i guess
um but it seems to have morphed into
something else
so you know just the other day i saw a
video of a guy in
new york city park who was wearing a
trump hat he that's well within his
right to wear a trump hat
and black lives matter people a good
group of probably 50 or 100 people
were literally forcing him out of the
park getting right in his face
you know pushing him a little bit all
this stuff i mean that
is a threat to free speech and democracy
a guy just
expressing a political opinion with a
hat and i've seen the movement sort of
morph into more of that
than i think what it should be about or
is supposed to be about
absolutely i think like you said the
movement has changed i think the
movement has become
super toxic i think like most social
movements it begin with you know an idea
that is well intentioned and maybe we
even should talk about it i think police
brutality
is an actual topic that needs to be
discussed and i think it's a shame that
black lives matter has
kind of made it so a lot of people don't
want to talk about it um
it started with a good intention and
then like most leaderless movements
it really just took a crap you know i
mean
what we see is that they don't actually
care about black lives i'm have you seen
that
young i think it's like a 17 year old
who i think he did like an interview on
infowars or something he's a trump
supporter
and right now there's people like from
black lives matter like searching for
him oh i did see it
unbelievable that kid yeah it's it's
insane and all the while hashtagging
black lives matter while they're hunting
down a black person
simply because they want to vote for
trump it's it's crazy but i did make
videos about black lives matter
um i made one entitled you know straight
to the point i entitled it um
black lives matter is trash and i got a
huge blow back from that it obviously
was shared amongst black lives matter
you know obviously my
viewership enjoyed it but lives matter
did not
and there was a huge doxing fiasco they
were trying to dox me
um i had to go off social media i saw
that you tweeted that you thought i had
been banned from twitter
yeah it's reasonable because a lot of us
are being banned lately but it wasn't
the case i was actually kind of just
laying low
while black lives matter was trying to
ruin my life yeah so for the people that
aren't in it with the with all the
internet lingo
so you were doxxed which basically means
somebody
uh pretty much they found out where you
live right and made that information
public
and they can get all other sorts of info
not just your physical location
but they can get banking records and all
kinds of stuff i mean this is a
huge threat to free speech because once
you have
this sort of blackmail on people and
then they go after someone who
publicly is saying things that are
unpopular
it's the chilling effect i mean that's
my thing with the milo thing i want milo
back on twitter for for many reasons
and i miss his voice on there um but to
me it's the chill effect
of okay we got rid of milo how many
other people are going to stop saying
what you think
regardless of whether i agree with them
or not yeah absolutely
you know even aside from twitter banning
people
you voice any type of conservative view
um
the doxing is a threat to free speech i
mean
when you use intimidation or threats of
violence to silence someone that is
literally stifling free speech
so i mean i didn't let it stop me i just
went laid low for
two days or whatever and then i came
back and i doubled down with another
video about that live
matter but um now i understand why a lot
of people when they do youtube videos
they use
anonymous pictures and names because it
actually is difficult to you know stamp
your name on something i think
you know it means more when you do stamp
your name on something but
there's also a huge risk that goes along
with that yeah you know i
struggle with that big time because
people message me all the time saying
you know you're so brave you're putting
this stuff out there
free speech blah blah blah and i i'm
just doing what i think is right
i don't think i'm actually that special
or anything i'm just doing
i've got some thoughts firing around up
here and i and i say them and that's
really it
but i do sometimes get frustrated by the
amount of people that are in the free
speech movement that are only doing it
as anonymous people and i get it
i get there's a real threat people feel
like if they say something i'm
politically correct
they're going to lose their job or all
that but in a weird way does that show
we're actually
losing because so many of us that are
that are trying to fight
for what is what is real equality what
is real honesty and what is really free
speech
feel the need already to be anonymous
which makes it seem like it would only
get worse even though there's
obviously some awakening going on here
yeah
honestly you know i talked about this
the other day with someone i do think in
a sense it does mean that we're
we have a huge battle ahead of us the
fact that most of us
don't stamp our name on it because it
has huge social implications i mean i
told you
about you know how feminists tried to
get me evicted from when i was living
black lives matter tried to dox me i
lost a shitload of friends
um i could imagine that what i say
online if i wasn't doing youtube full
time if i were to go apply for a job at
wherever
i would have difficulty doing that um so
it's i think there's something to be
said for the fact that you google
feminist youtubers everyone will have
their full name picture all that
if you google you know anti-feminism
anti-islam antibodies matter everyone
has like a cartoon picture
yeah god it's so clear to me and
especially when i talk to someone like
you
it's just so clear to me that we're on
the right side of this
because we're having a consistent set of
principles that we're standing for
which is actually for the minority and
the free thinker
and for the actual muslim person
and for the trans person because we want
these people to all be treated equally
not specially and we have got to crush
this thing it just seems so obvious as
i'm talking to you
no we have to and you know you brought
it up i think we actually are losing the
fact that milo was banned the fact that
a lot of us are forced into anonymity a
lot of us are forced off the internet
when we're doxxed
um i think it's more important than ever
than just to just speak
but i understand the implications that
go along with that yeah you know a
couple times you've mentioned that
you've lost some friends in this battle
and i've said several times on the show
i lost a bunch of friends when i started
talking about this too
and i've gained a whole bunch of new
better friends so so that's okay but i
get emails all the time people saying
i'm losing friends or i can't post this
on facebook or this one blocked me or my
sister won't talk to me i mean
really some crazy nonsense um when you
lost
friends can you give me an example of
like what that like one time and how
that conversation went
because i got i can give you example of
like just people that i've known
for many many years that suddenly out of
nowhere dave you're a bigot and a racist
and i'm not going to talk to you anymore
and
and then that's it and then stop
responding to texts and calls and it's
like
i don't think i've said anything
remotely bigoted or racist i'm trying to
have hard conversations
and it's just it's just a sad state of
affairs no it is
um i think you and i might be similar in
the sense that
being gay and being trans a lot of our
social circle was
was liberals and while by social circle
was people who were more inclined to the
sjw mindset and so when it comes to
starting to break out of that it's kind
of like leaving a cult
i'm just going to be honest kind of like
leaving a call i mean
i lost like at least 15 friends like in
one day
first day youtube and all of a sudden i
noticed a shift and no one talking to me
some people actually vocalizing that
what i what i was doing was so wrong and
um people talking about me i think that
a lot of people
i've heard a lot of messages as well
people saying they're losing family
or they lost their job i think it sucks
it really sucks yeah do you think
politics has become the new religion
uh because it seems to me that in the
old days
or for all time of human history we were
divided by religions now we still have
plenty of
religious division in the world without
question but it seems to me more than
ever right now and partially this is
because of i think our two crappy
candidates
running and just our whole political
machine is broken in america and all
that
but now people are being divided on
political lines we're in the
it used to be i i know when i was
growing up my family table we'd have big
family events
everyone be arguing over politics and
all believed in all kinds of different
things and we'd be screaming
and then at the end everybody was fine
and we all went ahead and
love each other and that's it but now it
seems like if you have if you know
somebody that's a trump supporter
that somehow you're a racist and you
know somebody that's a hillary supporter
you're somehow a wall street
sellout and all that and it's like this
is crazy
yeah it's i think it's all so
emotionally charged i mean
it's almost impossible to have any type
of political discourse without
people just freaking out on both ends
i'm not even gonna say it's like
just a yeah you know sjw thing i think
on both ends people
take it super seriously and you know i'm
probably guilty of doing that sometimes
as well but i do make a conscious effort
to like
not take everything so seriously i mean
objectively what i talk about are
serious topics but
i think it's nice to present them in a
way that's just a little bit
light-hearted that's why a lot of my
videos
are you know comedic in nature um
because it's just everything's so heavy
lately i know everyone feels that
everything's just so
heavy yeah well isn't that the funny
thing about what they call [ __ ]
posting online it's like all of these
people
i'm not saying you're doing it but when
i see all these it's funny to hear you
saying
[ __ ] posting online oh well i'm trying
to
for the people that don't know what [ __ ]
posting is i was trying that was for the
older audience you know what i mean i
know the kids know what the [ __ ] posting
is but basically
for people that don't know what [ __ ]
posting is it's basically intentionally
trying to inflame
people to get them to react and i see
this all the time you know i see all
these
these trump nazis posting all this stuff
and i see the
frog and all this crap and to me it's
like i either ignore it or i think some
of it's funny and some of it's scary and
annoying but it's like all right you're
some guy you did that
you're not at my house with a pitchfork
but then they get
they get celebrities and and journalists
and big name people to react
and then it seems like there's something
much bigger going on here
when really all it is is some kid with
photoshop
who took hitler and put him on trump and
people go bananas and it's like you
didn't really
you didn't really do anything leslie
jones that's what happened with leslie
jones it was
her this is why people say do not feed
the trolls because you know she was
married to someone then everyone
realized oh we'll get a reaction then
and so we'll post about her being a
gorilla and we'll post about
you know anything that will humiliate
her and she was like going to war with
these twitter accounts with like anime
pictures and like people who aren't you
know
it's funny and but but that's the reason
why milo was banned also which really
sucks that the fact that people really
perceive it to be
that there's just this many like hateful
evil people when really it's just people
[ __ ] with you because it's the
internet and you can't have high
expectations for the internet
that's why a lot of people ask me like
how do you deal with like the hate
comments it's like
it's the internet it's not like i
probably would be depressed if i was
walking down the mall and someone just
screamed [ __ ] at me but it's the
internet it's not a big deal
that's what i always say and i've really
come around on this it's like
if some random nut bag with an anime
picture or a twitter egg starts
screaming at me
it's like listen if i was walking down
the street and some crazy person started
screaming at me i would ignore them i
wouldn't engage them
and have a battle of ideas with a crazy
person and yet
and yet people think if a cat does it
to you you better respond or you're
gonna lose you know the interesting
thing about leslie jones by the way is
i've
i didn't know this till yesterday i have
never interacted with her i've never
tagged her in a tweet
i've never i don't think i've even ever
said her name publicly even when i did
my video about milo i'm not even sure
that i brought her up
specifically never interact with her i
just saw yesterday that she has me
blocked on twitter which kind of tells
you everything you need to know about
this
this level of discourse i was going to
invite her on the show that's why i went
to check
i was about to just say come on in let's
have an honest open conversation the way
i would do with anyone else
and she's got me blocked yeah a lot of
times they use block bots which is
basically like they'll automatically
block anyone who was a follower of the
same milo yiannopoulos
so a lot of times that's what happens as
well like you'll come across an sjw and
you've never interacted with them but
they have you blocked so that's what
that is but
um that's the whole you know echo
chamber thing it's the whole i don't
want to hear anyone else's opinions i
always want to spout my [ __ ] and no one
can respond
which people think that that's like a
violation of free speech i don't think
that is i think that's a little dramatic
to say you're silencing free speech
because
it's the internet everyone has their own
platform like it doesn't matter how big
or small it is everyone can say what
they want
i mean i'm i'm all for that say whatever
the hell you want as long as you're not
calling for direct violence
or or doxxing someone's you know some
without a direct threat beyond that say
whatever you want
and be the be the bigger person and if
somebody's saying something you don't
like
they got the mute button or they got the
block button or just ignore them
and uh life will go on won't it yeah
absolutely
yeah it is the internet well you know
what you you do so much of what you do
on the internet and i i love what you do
and i think you're doing such
great stuff uh do you have do did we
miss anything here i think we hit all
the big points
i don't think so i think we talk about a
lot of stuff
yeah when are you when are you making it
down to la so we can do this in person
next time
uh anytime anytime i'm i do youtube
full-time
so my schedule is pretty clear besides
making videos so
that's pretty that's pretty sweet what
did you think it was going to happen so
quickly that you could actually
be a full-time youtuber as they say no
no i mean listen the money is not i'm
not sitting here like
i'm not sitting here living the pan for
life it's a youtube channel people but
at the same time
you know i'm able to support myself and
just focus on making videos now which is
great
so yeah well that's all that's what it's
all about well listen
for whatever it's worth even though i
don't even like the phrase ally you know
you have an ally in me
and i have a feeling we'll continue to
do some stuff together and
you guys can find out more about blair
check out her
totally not politically correct youtube
channel it's youtube.com
blairwhitex and thanks a lot blair
thank you bye dave
you